l'histoire en question violente
polémique entre jacques chirac et jean
marie le pen
après l'indépendance la lettonie bat a
lancé une nouvelle monnaie
réduit 10 à 9 le champion de france
toulouse élimine narbonne de justesse
et puis la qualité c'est noir le
chanteur québécois robert charlebois
bonsoir mais d'abord la colère en
bretagne celle des victimes de l'ouragan
qui avait sinistré la région ouest en
1987 cent cinquante mille sinistrés
n'ont toujours pas été indemnisés
manifestation à rennes commentaires
jean-jacques malmanche la note de
l'ouragan de 87 n'est toujours pas soldé
chiffres cités par le collectif des
sinistrés 12 milliards de francs de
dégâts dont 9 qui reste à la charge des
victimes privées ou publiques
derrière la sécheresse de ce bilan des
situations de détresse qui s'aggrave
dette saisi faillite
c'est le lot des oubliés qui ont cumulé
les malchances exemple le cas d'une
commerçante finistérienne dans le
contrat d'assurance avait été modifié à
son insu lorsqu'il ya eu l'ouragan de
1987 elle s'est aperçue tentes et perry
venu il ya dit madame vous êtes assurés
pour la partie commerciale mais vous
n'êtes plus assurée pour la partie
maison 150000 breton s'estiment spoliés
pour cela pas d'indemnisation des
assurances pas dette de l'état seul
avancées récentes le ministre des
finances a promis de rouvrir le dossier
le collectif qui lutte depuis deux ans
pour faire reconnaître les droits de ces
sinistrés eux maintenant organiser la
solidarité internationale nous entendons
réunir les assises internationales des
victimes des catastrophes naturelles de
façon à ce que nos problèmes qui sont
ceux des ouragans des inondations des
sécheresses des marées noires et
également de la pollution soit pris en
charge globalement et nous permettent
d'accéder aux médias internationaux de
façon à faire connaître quelque chose
qu'on occulte est complètement politique
et polémique
jean-marie le pen envisage ce soir de
porter plainte contre jacques chirac le
ton est monté aujourd'hui dans les
relations entre le front national et le
rpr en fait tout a débuté hier soir en
alsace lorsque jacques chirac a évoqué
le comportement des militants d'extrême
droite pendant l'occupation allemande
je n'ai pas vu beaucoup lorsque je lis
les comptes rendus de ce qui s'est passé
pendant la guerre de gens se rattachant
à la famille d'extrême droite figurer
dans les rangs de la résistance il avait
plutôt pour place la collaboration je ne
pourrais pas admettre la moindre
concession à un accord quelconque avec
des dirigeants d'une formation dont les
racines les valeurs ont toujours été
al'inverse des nôtres des dirigeants qui
au titre de leur notion du débat
démocratique ont essayé d'assassiner le
général de gaulle est à plusieurs
reprises par monsieur chirac que s'il a
des documents ils auraient dû les
transmettra à la justice je pense me
suis aperçu qu'il ne se bornait pas à
citer l'extrême droite auquel cas
j'aurais pu ne pas me sentir visés mais
qu'il visait très directement le front
national alors ça c'est peut-être plus
facile à faire que d'expliquer
l'hémorragie de des effectifs du rpr et
les pertes électorale subie mais en ce
qui me concerne je ne regrette rien de
ce que j'ai fait faire ni pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale où ce que j'ai
fait est un honneur ni après ni en ado
chine ni en algérie des endroits où on
vend par des sifflets d'autres bals que
les balles de tennis
1 réaction de jean marie le pen
recueillis par daniel sportive alors
michel merle derrière l'offensive de
jacques chirac
c'est le retour aux sources du gaullisme
qui traduit la nouvelle stratégie de la
terre
oui la réconciliation entre jacques
chirac et charles pasqua s'était faite
autour d'une ligne politique beaucoup
plus offensif du rpr la principale cible
c'est avant tout le gouvernement mais le
risque pour le rpr c'est qu'actuellement
il y à un discrédit qui pèse sur
l'ensemble de la classe politique
française
tous les sondages le montrent or on peut
très bien se trouver dans une situation
où le rpr arrive à susciter un vote
protestataire plus important contre le
gouvernement mais que cette manne
électorale ne tombe pas dans sa cagnotte
mais à grossir l'escarcelle de
jean-marie le pen
d'où la nécessité de placer quelques
points de suture sur sa droite pour
éviter cette hémorragie alors il y a
dans les deux électorats des valeurs qui
sont assez proches sur la sécurité ou
sur le nationalisme il y à un point de
rupture évident dans l'inconscient
nationale c'est le rôle pendant la
guerre et l'occupation
or le rpr a le sentiment que c'est le
talon d'achille de jean marie le pen et
utilisera d'autant plus cet argument on
va rentrer de plain pied dans une allée
de gaulle 50e anniversaire de l'appel
dixième de la mort centièmes la
naissance de la naissance donc retour
aux valeurs du gaullisme c'était aussi
la volonté de charles pasqua si en plus
ça peut se faire au détriment du front
national c'est pour eux tout bénéfice
merci michel le maire robert charlebois
je vous ai entendu rire celle que
polémique dans la vie politique
française c'est une chose qui ne se
produit pas au québec non ça arrive sans
un vrai bien sûr c'est c'est celle à qui
chante je veux plus de semaine à l'open
si j'ai bien compris mais je trouve que
le pain engraissés par caen c'est le
salut est le stress alors sachez
toujours à propos l'actualité politique
que le rpr ne participera pas le 16 mai
prochain à matignon à la table ronde sur
l'immigration devant le conseil national
du rpr donc réunis ce soir à paris
berlin juppé a évoqué je cite
l'apparence de concertation au sein d'un
mouvement qui n'a par ailleurs pas
encore retrouvé toute sa sérénité
reportage éric pineault
les responsables du rpr avait décidé de
se mettre un boeuf sur la langue de
mettre leurs divergences en sourdine
pour mieux concentrer tirs sur les
socialistes en difficulté depuis
plusieurs jours sur la sphère de
l'aministie tout se passait comme prévu
jusqu'au moment où alain juppé a rendu
public à la tribune un accord secret
conclu au dernier bureau politique sur
un code de bonne conduite que les uns et
les autres se doivent de respecter mais
l'expression des courants
[ __ ] chose inévitable dans la nature
des choses ne veut pas dire fractionné
est ce la raison pour laquelle nous
avons pensé qu'il était bon d'adopter un
code de conduite
les amis de charles pasqua qui se sont
immédiatement senti délier de leur
réserve
on dit tout haut dans les couloirs ce
qu'ils ont sur le coeur irak et alain
juppé vous ont floués job je pense
qu'ils n'ont pas eu une attitude pinet
n'ont pas respecté leur accord c'est
tout c'est simple
jacques chirac et alain juppé qui
voulait donner une image rassemblé du
rpr pour repartir à l'offensive était
déçu ce soir mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que charles pasqua et ses amis n'ont pas
renoncé à prendre le contrôle du
mouvement
à l'étranger la conférence de + 4 /
l'allemagne ouverte au mois de juillet à
la pologne les ministres des affaires
étrangères des deux allemagne et des
quatre puissances victorieuses de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
lemmy les affaires étrangères donc ont
décidé d'intégrer ponctuellement
varsovie au débat sur la place dans
l'europe de la future allemagne unie
commentaires de mme hartmann la
conférence 2 + 4 sur le futur statut
militaire de l'allemagne réunifiée s'est
achevée aujourd'hui à bonn sur un
constat de divergence de +4 ou plutôt
cinq miss un compte tenu de la position
soviétique qui refusent l'adhésion du
futur état germanique à l'otan les
occidentaux n'ont pas réussi à
convaincre le ministre soviétique
edouard chevardnadzé et une prochaine
réunion aura lieu cette fois à paris en
juillet les soviétiques propose
l'adhésion simultanée de l'allemagne
réunifiée à l'otan et au pacte de
varsovie la divergence est sérieuse a
dit edwards chez vernaz et mais il ne
faut pas dramatiser séduire le bon
climat de la négociation les occidentaux
proposent des garanties contractuelles
aux soviétiques ce et en particulier la
non extension au territoire de
l'actuelle rda du dispositif militaire
de l'otan le pacte atlantique pourrait
même évoluer vers une structure plus
politique
reste que sur proposition du ministre
français roland dumas la pologne
participera aux prochains pourparlers et
l'allemagne pourraient reconnaître dans
le cadre d'un traité international la
frontière oder nice
quant à l'américain james baker il a
souligné qu'une fois la réunification
allemande effective
les quatre puissances victorieuses de la
seconde guerre mondiale devrait
abandonner leur sonatel sur l'état
germanique une page de notre histoire
sera tourné à bucarest en roumanie les
grévistes de la faim ont décidé de
poursuivre leur mouvement malgré la
décision du président intérimaire yoni
liège coup d'ouvrir le dialogue et de
rencontrer mardi prochain les
contestataires
monsieur dumitrescu porte-parole des
grévistes a déclaré que après en avoir
discuté ensemble les 57 grévistes
avaient décidé à l'unanimité donc de
poursuivre ce mouvement jusqu'à la
satisfaction de leurs revendications ou
jusqu'à la mort
interdiction par exemple pour leurs
revendications interdiction pour les
anciens cadres du parti communiste
d'être candidat à l'élection du 20 mai
report des élections du 20 mai purement
et simplement et puis la démission
revendiquer du ministre de l'intérieur
robert charlebois les événements dans
les pays de l'est la roumanie qui
cherche toujours la voie difficile va la
démocratie ce sont des choses que vous
avez suivi
oui avec beaucoup d'intérêt évidemment
je souhaite et je rêve un jour que la
roumanie soit complètement démocrate et
je crois qu'ils sont francophiles en
plus donc ça serait telle histoire
fantastique pour les artistes français
si nous aime et qu'on est con vas chez
eux qu'on peut chanter en français très
fantastique
maintenant je crois que là ils ont sauté
de la poêle à frire dans le feu un peu
comme les haïtiens au départ de bébé doc
parce qu'ils ont été remplacés par
pareille en fait que ceausescu enfin la
même lignée mais maintenant je leur
souhaite de tout cas de d'apprendre la
liberté est ce qu'ils sont vraiment
prêts à faire des entreprises et avoir
des commerces parce que ces gens là sont
tellement habitués à être prise en
charge depuis toujours ils sont enfin je
pense avec une question d'éducation mais
que ça va être long pour ça ça peut
prendre jusqu'à l'an 2000 avant qu'ils
apprivoisent la liberté mais je leur
souhaite de tout cas je leur souhaite
rapidement une démocratie
alors sachez s'agissait pas du tout par
contre sachez que les choses vont vite
dans la petite république de lettonie
après la proclamation d'indépendance
c'est le lancement d'une nouvelle
monnaie qui est activement à l'étude
ambiance et situation économique et
rigueur reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux hélène risacher et joseph tual
premières heures de l'indépendance de
lettonie je me sens libre livre et je
suis sûr que petit à petit la situation
économique va s'améliorer
bien sûr quelques anti indépendantistes
de l'interféron ont manifesté ce matin
mais de nombreux russes qui vivent dans
lettonie accepte cette indépendance
moi ça ne me gêne pas cette indépendance
tout est normal ici ça permettra
peut-être de régler la crise économique
car évidemment la lettonie n'échappe pas
aux pénuries soviétique le savon le
sucre la lessive sont rationnés on ne
trouve plus de café dans les magasins le
plus l'indépendance politique n'a aucun
sens sans l'indépendance économique
d'où le plan des autorités
indépendantistes créer un fonds
lettonien pour recueillir 10 millions de
dollars d'ici un an
afin de restaurer le late la moneda vent
l'annexion soviétique de 1940
non si moscou fait un blocus économique
contre nous nous n'attendons rien de
l'étranger
nous ne comptons que sur nous simplement
nous retarderons la mise sur le marché
international du lat
mais nous accueillerons bien sûr toutes
les aides de l'extérieur de toute façon
les trois pays baltes sont ensemble et
nous nous croyons à l'indépendance de la
lettonie aussi fort que nos
prédécesseurs
en 1918 la lettonie a appelé à
l'ouverture de négociations avec le
kremlin
mais l'indépendance lettone est un défi
à moscou le port de riga et une
ouverture stratégique et économique
essentiel avec la mer baltique
les lettons veulent récupérer ses
activités instaurée progressivement
l'économie de marché mairiga est une
plaque tournante que l'union soviétique
ne veut pas perdre climat de confiance
en l'afrique du sud après trois jours de
négociations entre la nc et le
gouvernement l'organisation de monsieur
mandela pourrait abandonner la lutte
armée mais on ignore encore la nature
des concessions du gouvernement de
monsieur de clerck qui arrivera à paris
en début de semaine commentaires
d'hubert coudurier une amnestie général
et la fin des procès politiques en
échange d'une suspension de la lutte
armée qui était devenu plus symbolique
que réelle
ce premier accord devrait ouvrir la voie
à des négociations longues et complexes
entre l'aele c est le gouvernement sud
africain
mais la volonté d'aboutir semble avoir
été également partagé au cours des
derniers jours
la levée de l'état d'urgence départ
encore d'actualité compte tenu des
troubles qui ensemble toujours le natal
et la réforme constitutionnelle qui
s'annonce ne sera pas simple à mettre en
oeuvre
côte à côte nelson mandela et frederik
de klerk n'en sont pas moins désireux de
faire preuve de bonne volonté de
sérénité ne serait ce que pour contenir
leurs propres extrémistes
je dis cela nous devons décentraliser le
pouvoir le limité pour protéger les
droits individuels et créer un véritable
droit des gens comme cela se passe en
suisse avec la pratique du référendum de
manière à ce que les gens puissent de
préférence à un niveau local décider eux
mêmes et cela afin de dépolitiser
l'afrique du sud toutefois deux
conceptions s'opposent celle de la haine
s'est fondé sur le principe un homme une
voix celle du gouvernement qui souhaite
maintenir le système des groupes raciaux
afin de protéger la minorité blanche
trente ans après l'interdiction de la
haine c'est le premier pas est
prometteur mais tout reste à faire sur
le chemin difficile de la réconciliation
entre les communautés
alors robert charlebois au delà de ce
problème bien particulier de l'apartheid
en afrique du sud
le racisme que l'on connaît en france
existe aussi au québec
non moi personnellement je suis un
agronome parce que je trouve que la
musique je parle de ce que je connais
doit beaucoup au noir que ce soit depuis
gershwin ou guy carmichael même les
beatles ont beaucoup pompe et chuck
berry est en fait moi je pense qu'on
était à se connaître et qu'on peut
apporter beaucoup de choses
maintenant on est différent aussi mais
on est condamné à se partager cette
planète alors il faut savoir travailler
ensemble et savoir quand sortirait un
moment donné pour que chacun respecte la
culture de l'autre et tout cela devrait
se passer dans l'harmonie ya aucun pour
l'instant racisme au québec
si ce n'est que les anglais nous ont
donné un spectacle très laid depuis un
mois ils sont blancs les autres faits
marquants à l'actualité sous forme de
télégrammes avec le commentaire de
jacques baudrier
et morts et 16 blessés après un
tremblement de terre dans le sud de
l'italie le séisme a atteint 7 degrés
sur l'échelle de mercalli qui en compte
la secousse principale a duré pas moins
de 40 secondes ce qui a provoqué de
nombreuses scènes de panique
en 81 tremblement de terre dans la
région avaient fait près de 3000 morts à
ouvéa en nouvelle calédonie cérémonie à
la mémoire de jean marie tjibaou et
yeiwéné yeiwéné et de chefs
indépendantistes avaient été assassinés
dans l'île il y a un an par l'un des
leurs le successeur de jean marie
tjibaou à la tête du fn k s a appelé à
l'union du mouvement kanak
la commission des opérations de bourse
dresse le portrait robot de l'initier
est donc un initié celui qui disposent
d'une information privilégiée en raison
de sa fonction
celui qui a communiqué cette information
ou bien la personne qui montrent une
opération financière enfin depuis ce
matin les toulousains n'ont d'yeux que
pour leur cathédrale un antiquaire
course une grève de la faim au sommet de
la basilique saint sernin
ils protestent contre la fermeture du
village des antiquaires dans la ville
rose
l'homme est déterminé il a affirmé qu'il
ne descendrait que lorsqu'un accord sera
intervenu en france encore deux avions
de tourisme se sont télescopés il ya un
peu moins d'une heure à wambrechies près
de lille
il y aurait 7 un bilan provisoire un
mort et un blessé
les secours sont arrivés très rapidement
l'inde est à lyon s'est écrasé sur un
hangar de caravanes alors que le
deuxième avion lui a réussi à se poser
sur l'aéroport c'est donc qu'il ya moins
d'une heure à wambrechies dans le nord
images tournées par la station et faire
3 lille dossier les problèmes
d'intégration des harkis en france
ils étaient soixante mille en 1962 ils
sont près de 400 mille aujourd'hui la
mise en place aujourd'hui d'un énième
nouveau plan pour résoudre leurs
problèmes sera-t-il suffisant
reportage dans la communauté harkie de
graulhet eric thybaud 1962-65 famille
art qui arrive à graulhet
une trentaine d'entre elles s'installent
ici à moulin neuf
un quartier construit à la va vite qui
devient en quelques années un ghetto à 7
km de la ville
aucun transport en commun n'est prévue
et bail à loyer ça mais le frein à laval
à un garage quoi le cochon bardot serait
maintenant homogène
petit à petit les harkis qui tu roules
1,9 et s'installe à grouiller il achète
une maison travaille dans le cuir et
maintenant ils sont à la retraite
aujourd'hui reste leurs enfants un sur
deux n'a pas de travail et ne redécouvre
que l'intégration ne s'arrête pas un
logement acheté à crédit et un petit
boulot de temps en temps c'est vrai que
je mens pas une vie pour moi c'est pas
une vie moins ce que je veux je veux tu
elle fonde une famille travailler pour
une famille n'est pas compter sur mes
parents parce que j'ai 21
l'internât mais je veux dire en 30 ans
bon c'est pas une vie
moi je pense qu'on a les mêmes droits
que les autres mais compagnies se sont
battus pour la france dont ils ont versé
leur sang pour la france la france
qu'est ce qu'elle a refait les a laissés
de côté maintenant on mélange les arts
guy avec les immigrés moi je ne sais pas
normal je vous dimanche mais moi ce que
j'aimerais qu'on me fasse nous les
artistes qu'on nous fasse france à part
entière même si le fond moi je marquerai
fille d'arqués sur le principe web
français ils ne sont officiellement
leurs parents avaient reçu de l'argent
du gouvernement pour acheter une maison
mais les enfants ne veulent plus de ça
ils souhaitent qu'on les écoute qu'on
s'intéresse à leurs difficultés
d'aujourd'hui et qu'on les aide à
trouver un vrai travail des sports en
rugby toulouse a tremblé jusqu'à la
dernière minute cet après-midi pour
éliminer narbonne le héros du jour denis
charvet
reportage à agen andré marc marc métais
rouge et le noir des champions de france
flotter pourtant sur le stade armandie
cet après-midi âge mais c'étaient les
narbonnais qui ouvraient le score grâce
à l'espion qui passe une première
pénalité des audois très accrocheur en
début de rencontre une balle pour henri
sa chandelle de jean marc lescure est à
la réception un regroupement très chaud
une conquête qui sera audoise où
en abonnés directement sur campos à
suivre dans l'angle le ton était donné
nouvelle pénalité en faveur de narbonne
et contre toute attente les narbonnais
mener 6 à 0 et que vous un piqué au vif
faisait feu de tout bois avec un retour
en forme qu'un chanteur a tout le monde
celui d'eric bonneval une balle pour
david berty l'action n'aboutira pas
laisser du stade toulousain est le seul
essai de cette rencontre le voici une
valve pour 2 michel est en position
d'ailier il va taper à suivre pour ces
compagnies à thomas clavières 7 à 6 pour
le tapis rouge
ce sera le score à la mi temps
bien sûr rajoutons à 3.917 narbonne
repasser devant le deuxième héros du
stade toulousain le voici
philippe rougé thomas qui passait le
drop de la victoire design pour le staff
toulousain avec l'autre héros denis
charvet
vous aimez le rugby robert charlebois
général américain le cricket au baseball
alors je comprends viennent-ils que 4
news b alors j'aime trop les deux eaux
si on parlait musique maintenant votre
nouveau disque qui s'appelle dans ce but
non pas comme on le dance malice dans ce
cas manille dans ce village est très
touffu
il est dense il aidera à faire ça sinon
rse ac est un événement n'aviez pas
sorti de disque depuis a depuis moi très
lente des bons ça fait peut-être au
moins sept ans on les considère toujours
là peut on en est c'est un bout tout de
suite c'est possible
le terrain
c'est de l'amour
oui
c'est bon c'est chaud à vendre
bien dans sa peau
et deux
alors c'est vrai ça balance toujours
autant c'est gmi peut-être 2,1 à monter
leur caste de mes rêves le vous avez
reconnu l'enfant sera en fait vous savez
pour le connu parce que vous ne
connaissez pas vous avez apprécié jean
françois fabiano qui est un guadeloupéen
enfin qui est de père italien qui était
venu en suisse donc ils arrivent à
l'heure ce qui est un avantage
guadeloupe et les rythmes donc davantage
attiser non je fais une chanson à
caractère anti enfin j'appelle ça du
haut que moi mais pour les puristes
comme leeds et puis le groupe kassav ou
même la compagnie créole je serai jamais
un vrai zouk que je n'ai pas la
prétention non plus de faire du zouk
machine music
c'est un tempo que je trouve
extraordinaire images davis est d'accord
avec moi lui qui est assez exigeant
d'habitude de joie quand est-ce qu'on
verra sur scène en france
et bien vous allez concert vraiment
exceptionnel cet été le 15 ou à saint
nazaire à l'occasion des fêtes de la mer
et puis probablement fin 90 début 80 ans
je cherche un lieu où les gens peuvent
danser on écoute dans la halle aux
francofolies francofolies l'on pousse et
ça je le fais en 91
c'est l'urssaf et ferme ça oui et sinon
sur paris peut être un endroit où les
cabarets où les gens peuvent danser sur
la musique parce que pour un compositeur
je trouve ça formidable de voir des gens
bouger sur la musique
et puis les origines de la musique pop
stock ce soit bel et les hooligans mais
leur légende ans est meilleur la musique
est plus on a envie de danser dernier
reportage de ce journal l'inauguration à
lyon d'un nouveau lieu de culte il ne
s'agit pas encore de la mosquée mais
d'un temple bouddhiste installé par la
nombreuse communauté vietnamienne dans
la banlieue lyonnaise à lyon reportage
de carole donnait nous ne sommes pas au
vietnam et à sainte foy les lyon dans le
lieu de culte de l'association unique
rhône alpes la pagode qui élimine un
lieu souhaité depuis près de dix ans par
les trente mille âmes de la communauté
vietnamienne de la région un lieu devenu
nécessaire
avec l'augmentation du nombre de
bouddhistes pratiquants c'est en 1983
que la première pierre est posée nous
sommes en 1990
entre ces deux dates sait-on de
recherche et de travail nous avions
lancé une souscription pour la
construction cette pagode
on nous a même aidé par du travail
bénévole les dents ils ont été récoltés
au sein de la communauté vietnamienne
dans tous les pays
mais au delà de l'inauguration qu'on
fêtait aussi l'ordination de jeunes
disciples une première en europe et le
2500 34e anniversaire de la naissance de
bouddha
une fête qui va durer quatre jours
l'occasion pour la communauté
vietnamienne de se retrouver et de
partager traditions et coutumes
bouddhique
car comme le disent les vénérables nous
avons tous le même sens rouge et les
mêmes larmes salées et il est à tiercé
quarté + cet après midi à vincennes dont
voici tout de suite les rapports avec la
voix du connaisseur robert charlebois il
fallait jouer il fallait jouer en ordre
une set le 18 et le dise non 6-6 et pour
gérer moi je rêvais de faire la météo
très déçu de la performance est là pour
gagner 2000 68 francs et puis le
quartier plus c'est plus intéressant car
tu es plus la carte et plus alors il
fallait jouer le siècle 18 le 10 et 11
suis désolé ça n'apparaît pas pour
gagner dans l'ordre ai-je pu saluer mais
rien la vedette à 1 4266 en vain
netanyahu merci robert charlebois
d'avoir participé à ce journal dans un
instant la météo complète de florence
klein je vous retrouve à 22h cinq ans
pour chaque fois c'est bon début de
soirée à tous si avec